and so begins another appalling pretence
at justice in belarus
six political prisoners two of them
former presidential candidates
on trial in prison in what passes for a
courtroom
this is all we'll see of it the
proceedings are closed
all that svetlana tihanovskaya will see
of her husband
sergey who she has campaigned so
tirelessly for
since his and then her attempt to oust
the belarusian leader alexander
lukashenko
in last year's elections it's difficult
for
prisoners to understand that they will
not see
the eyes of their relatives and they
will argue with judges they will
give the the view of the situation but
nobody will
hear this and of course it's pity
the eu on thursday imposed its toughest
sanctions yet
targeting belarus's main exports and its
access to finance
in response to the hijacking of a
ryanair flight last month
a proper forceful hit whatever
lukashenko says
who were arrested off that flight have
been moved to house arrest
perhaps protosevich has done all the
regime needed him to do
professed support for lukashenko all
most likely under terrible duress
it's disgusting to discuss
what he was saying it's we have to
discuss
how we have to release him that's it
long time political prisoner nikolai
statkovich on the right was pardoned in
2015.
jailed again last year his wife marina
thinks he won't be pardoned again
and is suspicious of rumors of an
amnesty
supervisory
the corruption trial of another of last
year's presidential hopefuls victor
babarika
and his associates is wrapping up the
prosecution asking for 15 years
natalia madskevich represents both
babarica and
sergey tikanovsky a losing battle she
knows
in a climate of unprecedented pressure
on lawyers like her
upstairs
optimistic
but the brave few keep fighting and if
the majority are silenced by the
regime's repressions
they see it for what it is
a cruel and vindictive dictatorship
determined to crush
every last breath of resistance rather
than lose its grip
on power dynamic
sky news moscow